i had the original oculus rift the
[ __ ] puke machine you put that thing
on your i gave it to my friend he went
and vomited in my driveway and people
were making fun of it they were saying
this isn't going to catch on it's too
big it's unwieldy the graphics suck and
then look at where it's at now
and that's going to keep
that trajectory is going to keep
improving so yeah i think that
we are dealing with what you're talking
about which is novelty met with
more problems met with novelty yeah i
wonder why vr is not more popular
i wonder what is going to be the magic
thing that really
um convinces a large fraction of the
world to move into the virtual world
i i suppose we're already there in the 2
2d screen of
twitter and social media that kind of
stuff even video games there's a lot of
people that get a a big sense of
community from video games
but like
it doesn't feel like you're living there
right like
it's like bye mom i'm going
i'm going to this other world yeah or
like you leave your girlfriend to go get
your digital girlfriend
that's gonna be a problem there's less
jealousy in the digital world maybe
there should be a lot of jealousy in the
digital world because that's jealousy
a little jealous is probably good for
relationships
yeah even in the digital world yeah so
you're gonna have to simulate all of
that kind of stuff but i wonder what the
magic thing that says i want to spend
most of my days inside the virtual world
well
clearly it's going to be something we
don't have yet i mean strapping that
damn thing on your face still feels
weird it's heavy
if you're depending on what what gear
you're using sometimes light can leak in
there's just you got to recharge it it's
hyper limited and then
so yeah
it's gonna have to be
something that like
simulates taste
smell you think tastes smaller important
touch i do yeah i can't just do you know
in world war ii you would write letters
you could still don't you think you can
convey love with just words
for sure but i think for what you're
talking about that happen it has to be
fully immersive like you so that it's
not that you
feel like you're walking because it
looks like you're walking but that your
brain is sending signals telling your
body that you're walking that you feel
the wind blowing in your face not
because of some i don't know fan or
something that it's connected to but
because somehow
it's figured out how to
hack into the human brain and send those
signals
minus some external thing it once that
happens i'd say we're gonna see
a complete radical shift in uh
everything see i disagree with you i
don't know if you've seen the movie her
yeah
i think you can go to another world and
where a digital being lives
in the darkness and all you hear is a
scarlet johansson voice
talking to you and she lives there or he
lives there your friend
your loved one
and all you have is voice and words and
i think that could be sufficient to pull
you into that world where you look
forward to that moment all day yeah you
never want to leave
that darkness just closing your eyes and
listening to the voice i think i think
those basic
mediums of communication is still enough
like language is really really powerful
and i think the realism of touch and
smell and all that kind of stuff
is not nearly as powerful as language
that's what makes humans really
special is our ability to communicate
with each other that's the sense of like
deep connection we get is through
communication now that communication
could involve touch like
you know
hugging
feels damn good you see a good friend
you hug
um that's one of the big things with
doing covert with rogan when you see him
there's a giant hug coming your way and
that makes you feel like yeah this is
this is this feels great but i think
that can be just with language i think
for a lot of people that's true
but
we're talking like
massive
adoption of a technology
by the world yeah and if language is
enough was just enough
uh we wouldn't be selling tvs
people would be this you'll be reading
they want to watch they want to see yeah
you know so
but i i agree with you man when you're
getting absorbed into a book and
especially if you've got i think a lot
of us went through a weird dark ages
when it came to reading like when i was
a kid and there wasn't the option for
these
hypno rectangles that's just what you
did there wasn't even anything special
about it what's the hypno right thing
your phone you know it was like you
didn't when that gravity well
gravity well it is attention gravity
well yeah when we weren't feeling the
pull of these things all the time you
would just read and you weren't patting
yourself on the back about reading you
just that's what you had you had that
and you had like
eight channels on the tv and a shitty
vcr so
you know then a lot of people stop
reading because of these things you know
or they think they're reading because
they're on they are technically reading
but you know when you return to reading
after a pause whoa
and you realize how powerful this
simulator is when it's given the right
code of language
whoa holy [ __ ] it's incredible i mean
it's like
again it's the most embarrassing kind of
like whoa
wow what do you know books are really
good yeah but still if you've been away
from it for a while and you revisit i
know what you're saying
i just think probably
it's
not going to go in that direction even
though you you are right ultimately i
think you're right yeah because our our
brain is the imagination engine we have
is able to fill in the gaps better than
a lot of graphics engines could right
and so if there's a way to incentivize
humans to become addicted to the use of
imagination it's like you know that's
the downside of things like porn that
remove the need for imagination
for people and in that same way video
games that are becoming ultra realistic
you don't have to imagine anything and i
feel like the imagination is really
powerful tool that needs to be leveraged
because to simulate reality sufficiently
realistically that we wouldn't be that
we would be perfectly fooled i think
technically it's very hard
so i think we need to somehow leverage
imagination
you